comment détermine-t-on un bon lycée le
taux de réussite au bac bien sûr mais
pas seulement le parisien a publié
mercredi dernier son classement annuel
des meilleurs lycées du département le
classement a fait émerger des
établissements qui sont moins sélectif
comme le lycée dumont-d'urville à mort
par la famille bourdilhan chaque année
c'est un rendez vous incontournable
il est attendu par tous les
établissements scolaires et par les
parents d'élèves
c'est le classement des meilleurs lycées
du département ici au lycée
dumont-d'urville de maurepas on se
réjouit une hausse de quatre points pour
se placer cette année à la 42e place en
un progrès fait l'an dernier nous étions
presque dans les derniers du classement
donc de 48 à 44 c'est une progression
toujours intéressant plusieurs critères
sont pris en compte le taux de réussite
au baccalauréat mais aussi des
indicateurs de performance comme la
valeur ajoutée d'accompagnement elle
mesure la capacité du lycée a gardé ses
élèves jusqu'au bac
nous avons des indicateurs qui ne sont
pas très bons parce qu'effectivement sur
ces indicateurs d'accompagnement il y a
un certain nombre d'élèves qui partent
sur les filières s tmg vers d'autres
lycées puisque nous n'avons que deux
spécialités sur quatre est
malheureusement nous n'avons pas les
deux spécialités les plus attractives
mais les deux spécialités les plus
spécialisés ou en tout cas les moins
attractives ce qui fait qu'on a un
déficit entre le nombre des partants et
le nombre d'élèves entrant dans le top
20 du classement cette année seulement
six établissements publics dont le lycée
descartes de montigny le bretonneux
arrivé 18e
un résultat qui s'explique entre autres
par le coût des études dans les lycées
privés
nous sommes à un lycée public et donc
notre mission est d'accueillir tous les
élèves et de les garder jusqu'à ce
qu'ils obtiennent un baccalauréat quelle
qu'elle soit avec 720 élèves en 2015 le
lycée dumont d'urville a atteint 90 % de
réussite au baccalauréat cette année il
vise les 93 % pour atteindre les
objectifs du rectorat et du ministère de
l'éducation
c'est